factorization meaning well what does
factorization means you've been doing it
for so long I have you've got a vibe yet
or the fact that I'll go after something
simple and I'll see if you really
understand it
they're almost yes what is cache
location yes routine works we have more
online expression could be like terms so
you have a more organized expression I
like that we are going to be doing quite
a lot of groups in segments and what you
end up with generally is much more
organized you can do lots of useful
things with factorized expression that
you can't do with unpasteurized
expression okay however I push on that
definition a little bit you guys have
seen in fact I've even written on the
board today you've seen this word and
you can ask to do it hours into time
okay I kind of do this is quite similar
to life organized right make it make it
look better simplify it more organized
way about the problem is the words
simplify is it it's incredibly ambiguous
okay sometimes you could argue that this
is simpler now what I'm going to write
what we're all going to write in a
minute when I factorize okay and I
wonder if you can argue why simplifying
sometimes we factorize and sometimes it
may expand okay let's pretend it's a
little more what makes an expression
pasteurize as opposed to unpack right
what's missing from these things it
tells you it's all matter directly
bracket okay there are brackets missing
so I'm going to add some
say expression go bracket down is a
factorize to grasp it brackets are
necessary but not sufficient one way
with the bracket they need to be doing
something specific this only give me an
expression just say an expression that
you know is factorize like a simple one
unless you're related to this one and
then we compare this one with that one
anyone 8 throwing up - you okay I gave
you download it that's fine okay good
let's go that insights into the sake of
it a little rising local okay so what is
it that this has if that doesn't have
right well we already identified the
bracket but any such as brackets to this
which doesn't make a factor there's a
symbol has been omitted from this a plus
B a plus B it implies you all can see it
there you will read it there but I
haven't written exquisite it's my
passion it's all just hiding right in
there okay when you are asked you to
factorize something you are being asked
to write it so that it has factors
aggradation
factors when you have a product the
pieces of the political factors right
that's why if I say that drives 24 you
could read a variety of ways can you
give me away
hey times me you can do it another way
you can you know what to come full
circle to either get going right I mean
that'll be boring true okay now all
those have been factorized right so
that's what we're trying to do here
you'll see why as well on this one what
is factorizing in a five minutes okay
give me suggestions what would you like
to do what a first thing
like on the first example turn getting
something a little better than one
example any suggestions
yes okay so I've got these army Palantir
right now I will deal with these house
they're very very important but for the
environment I'm actually going to leave
that off here's one um for solace I mean
I know I took this away but we know
about twigs and stuff where we also know
about cute these guys are cortex we
don't noticed so much of now we can deal
with them as you'll see in a minute but
we don't have to be totally don't have
like a result that I can just sort of
pull that and in speech ready mate okay
so being I'm going to leave that to
later is there anything else I can do
with the can factorize you know yeah
okay so there's a factor of distantly
variable Q right now I'm just going to
leave the negative net I mean one room
has one another so I'm just going take a
five why do you do that me if I take out
a factor all time what gets the point
six ax to the floor
yeah - why okay set up it good am I done
I'm not I should point out I wasn't a
any waiting for the question use but if
you get an to factorize we're always
asking you to factorize fully like keep
going okay I know that all right that
there's a both factors but you can do
more right now we've got to take on this
service for what can I do with it being
that I have no ready results and he's
just yeah ah sure even though I can't
deal with it as fours I can think of it
actually as sweat so the first thing I
should do is write these thing and
squares okay so what do I have to square
to give that what gets square do you go
for I join yet but there's a lot what
about the other part sir it's x squared
okay so for x squared if I square the
whole thing that'll do this
before you witness us on good okay then
what do i Square to get what for
cool all right you wouldn't so we've got
that index phone in our pocket and I'm
going to put some big bracket okay
having written these two thinkers
squares that make it a bit easier please
now through the difference of squares
doesn't right so here's my a squared is
like B squared
what is the difference of squares great
1 3 squared is equal to a minus B times
a plus B yes okay so let's write that
out here's the a and here is the big f
AE minus B in fact if you're we know a
little bit about eight months P you see
what I've done and then one concise over
here is it possible how do you braid
handle it now you should do with me I'm
just going to write this on this year
and I invite you to do this thing as
well
one of the reasons why I was watching
your eyes no one gave me a oh yeah I
know exactly what that next one is
because your brain so you get full like
they don't want stop nap in your brain
okay so use the paper to help you okay
then term memory and we're done
I'm close I'm almost there one of these
practice can be factorized but which one
this one I can go again contact because
it still differences where is this I'm
going to skip this step now either you
can do this and I can apply about the
front what would be my a minus B a plus
B so this disguise 2x minus y very good
and therefore 2 X plus y is a difference
of squares for second time a I do
anything at this time not really so I'm
just flipping okay I factorize okay now
this is why I was done sort of
questioning before I agree with Eric
that this is in some ways much more
organized than what I had before but in
other ways it's not like if I just gave
you a choice factorizing or not
factorize you can care that's it you can
let this one or you can write this one
which would you like to write I think
most which you like the first one okay
now the second one is superior in some
ways out of talk about those in a second
but it's not just simpler and not
necessarily just more organized it's
authorized in a particular okay